The Epic Games Launcher is a powerful piece of software that's used for managing and downloading
various versions of Unreal Engine as well as content that you've associated with those
versions of the Engine.
When you open up the Launcher, you're going to be greeted with something that looks like
this.
And no matter what you're using Unreal Engine for, you'll need to utilize the Launcher in
some way.
Let's take a look at the Launcher now.
So across the top we have our News, Sample, Fab, Library, Twinmotion, and Reality Capture.
News is where we're going to get the latest and greatest news about Unreal Engine, such
as new releases and anything that's happening in the community you might want to check out.
Samples are going to take us to any of the Unreal Engine sample content that you can
download and take apart to see how it was created so you can learn more about how Unreal
Engine works and help you with whatever project you happen to be building.
Fab takes us to the Start Exploring, which will bring us to the web version of Fab.
Our library allows us to at the top browse different versions as well as add versions
of Unreal that we might currently need to use or currently have installed.
For that we'll find my projects which show all the projects we have installed or created
for this particular computer.
And then underneath that we're going to have our Fab library, which shows us all of the
things we've collected from Fab that we can add or install for our particular engine or
to our project.
Now Twinmotion is, I like to refer to it as PowerPoint for 3D, and you can install that
by coming over to the Twinmotion category.
This is a great way for real-time visualization.
It's very, very simple to use.
And next to that we have Reality Capture.
Reality Capture is the desktop photogrammetry solution that Epic Games provides if you need
to process photogrammetry locally.
Now no matter what you're using Unreal Engine for, you're going to need to utilize the Epic
Games launcher in some way, shape, or form.
So just keep that in mind.
And I encourage you to explore especially the samples and the Fab section because there's
some really awesome and great stuff out there.
And the Epic Games launcher provides you a great way to access that content.